islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes
all of this and so much more can be on
your scale of good deeds click the link
and donate what you can
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters and
dear friends very strange a lot of
people who want to gain attention they
always can't find anything but in so
islam
not christianity not judaism not
hinduism not sikhism but it has to be
islam and that shows you how powerful
is that little weasels the little boys
little kids
making rap track you know paying
somebody you know broth you're just
begging
here's a video of a little slub of the
guardian yeah you can go to google and
check what that word means a little slub
of the guardian making a video and
calling allah a food let's watch this
little clown and be back
[Music]
so as you guys saw there
allah is afraid my friend you even know
what allah means allah means good there
are some arab christians coptic
christians who have been living in
christian lands uh islamic muslim lands
for many years that they use the word
allah so allah means god so say
allah is for disaster god is fault now
let's come to the whole issue of fraud
let me just break it down too easily it
seems that you don't know nothing about
christianity and we're going to come to
that because there's a little debate
with brother adele okay let's break this
down
let's talk about trinity the father the
son and the holy spirit yeah the father
is not the son the son is not the holy
spirit the holy spirit isn't the father
um or the son and but the father is god
the holy spirit is god and the son is
good
do you know that is one of the main
reasons why so many people are leaving
christianity because it makes no damn
sense
and it sounds like a fraud that sounds
like a real fruit how could you say the
god almighty who created the heavens and
the earth came down to earth like me
flesh and blood ate and walked and went
to the toilet and that is the god of the
heavens and the earth do you know there
are more stars on in our universe than
there are sand particles and you're
telling me the one that created every
single one of them came to earth walked
went to the toilet you know when you go
to the toilet and you have to
when you're pooing yeah god did that
my gosh
my gosh that to me is fraud number one
number two where do you get jesus's
divinity and the trinity the truth
doesn't even exist in the bible
um early church fathers didn't even the
holy spirit wasn't even in the picture
that came later yeah no problem
the trinity
jesus is death and his resurrection and
dying for your sins are all where where
did you get this information from from
where the holy spirit that descends on
you that you talk about a lot no where
did you get it you got it from the bible
hold on a second if you got it from the
bible the bible has to be a reliable
source
which bible are you talking about how
many books the one that you choose how
many books does it have how many the
point is this the scripture that you get
all of this from is corrupted you've got
many passages go to passages you've got
books missing there's passages that is
what i call fraud
that is fraud claiming something about
jesus that he himself didn't claim for
himself the bible has been accepted by
people like your own scholar scholars
yeah ex-christian bart ehrman bruce
metzger read their books read their
books that is what you call for do you
your bible doesn't even have
any reliability that is food you are
putting your whole soul
on the line for a book that you're
following that you don't even know who
it's from
number three
who is mark matthew luke and john who
the hell are these people
go and read jerome's new coming from the
uh the bible yeah and see what he says
about them we don't even know who the
hell john is john the son of zebedee
john the presbyter or john the apostle
which john are you talking about we know
nothing about them so you have a group
of people who have never met jesus never
ate with jesus never did anything with
jesus telling about jesus and what
happened and then we don't even know who
the hell they are
what we don't know nothing about them
and they are telling you about a bible
which has verses and passages added
inserted in go and read it for yourself
and books i didn't forget versus books
editing and then it's talking about god
almighty there is no way i'm going to
rely on someone that i don't know that
never met jesus telling me about a bible
that has been corrupted and in that
bible telling me that god is the trinity
that is nothing but fruit maybe you made
a mistake and you meant you know the
bible or the trinity
or these um writers people who were
inspired were fraught now let me end
with this let me end with this let's
watch this little clip in this little
clip you can clearly see a brother
muslim brother uh i think there's a deal
having a discussion with me look what he
says i'm so firm in the power of the
holy spirit that if you were to have any
pain or any sort of thing going on in
your life i could pray through the
screen and it would be healed i've been
at church and i've seen diabetics in the
name of jesus through the power of the
holy spirit their blood pressure
completely changed so you're telling me
you can heal people that are handicapped
jesus came through the power of the holy
spirit
why aren't you
why are you debating with me why aren't
you at hospitals right now
what do you mean i was just at a
hospital
you know when i saw this i was like
brother man why do you even waste my
time with this guy why are they wasting
my time with this he's healing brother
come and he'll go to the hospital he
goes i'm not medical ex
brother you said you heal with the holy
spirit
if you're here with the holy spirit you
should be a full-time brother i'll pay
you both go and heal people in the
hospital go on
stop chatting nothing with this holy
spirit thing etc you don't even know how
do you know it's not satan that's
talking to your brother how do you know
you have no basis you have no basis if
you want to learn about islam come and
talk to me no problem be civilized don't
be disrespectful come and we will teach
you we can have a nice discussion and we
can talk okay whatever your name is and
that's it i'm not going to long it out
too much inshallah yeah it's very clear
we ask you um all islam says is worship
god and god alone he has no partners he
is free of partners and there is nothing
like unto him worship him the one that
jesus worshiped along that's it it's not
rocket science mate till next time
assalamu alaykum
islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorize the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can